you've spoken so much about Italy over
the years you talk about Italian food
talk about gelato you talk about Italian
art your mouth is just constantly
shooting out diarrhea about Italy my
thought is of course we must go to Rome
Rome is great for cacio e pepe rome is a
sec what is that a comedy team no the
tachi oh and pepe rome is a sexy raw
city people are beautiful the men are
beautiful maybe you and I will be
inspired to make ourselves more gorgeous
in response do you think something's
gonna happen between us no but I think
that it's seeing a gorgeous man can
influence you is your plot now that you
and I go to Italy we find a third guy
maybe this cacio or this Pepe and then
we all hook up is that your plan now get
all oiled up with some olive oil because
that's not the way I roll I travel often
alone you're married why were you
traveling with her sometimes being alone
shuts out unnecessary distractions and
allows you to fully immerse yourself
just called your wife a necessary give
the objection is cultural immersion
where I prefer not to speak English like
jung-bae it's getting really close to my
eye I'm in full moon so we're fortunate
working in television we have a lot of
time off and a lot of other Americans
that have normal nine-to-five jobs maybe
get two weeks off a year now you got to
spend one of those weeks with your
family so really you're talking about
one good week off you just sent one with
your family but then one good we got if
you read between the lines you don't
like your family
this is contextual we're talking about
traveling you're taking the statement
out of context so after spending a
couple of days in Florence I Drive
throughout the Chianti Classico region I
know many of the people that live in
these towns and work in these residents
a year when they see you coming by
you're wearing your black shirt because
that's all you ever wear and you're
driving around in your red car alone
with those dead eyes what happens if
they pull the shutters shut did they get
the kids off the street is everyone
clear out of the way it must be sort of
like oh my god it's back the thing that
it travels alone is back that what
happens you know in the United States
there is a stigma against going out to
eat alone or sitting anywhere alone
we're in Europe it's commonplace you see
people taking time for themselves
reading their paper yeah catching up
with their own sure I'm gonna hear the
schoolyard yeah the kids give me a lolly
give you a lolly have you killed anyone
in Italy no how many people have you
killed in remote places and buried them
there I've never killed anybody in any
place hey you not there so there's no
murder victims in Italy there are plenty
I haven't committed those murders how do
you know because I would have remembered
it if I did he might be so detached from
reality so lost in this fog of faith
italiana that you don't know what you're
doing I'm not detached from reality at
all I'm very in touch with reality I
explore myself and people around me I've
heard you explore yourself you say
you've been to a lot of places in Italy
I was point to a place and you tell me
if you've been there sure yes absolutely
yes I've been there yes
been here yes been here no you haven't
been in the water that's the Adriatic
Sea yes have you been there no I'd like
to take you there okay I'd like you to
hold a rock for me just keep holding
onto it
out of there okay don't ever let go of
that rock you're gonna feel like you're
losing consciousness you're gonna be
fine when you wake up you'll be in hell
is it Bologna or Bellona alone yeah so
the G ends Bolognese is the magic tip
for belonging someone from Bologna is
Bolognese a style of ragu a meat sauce
for a pasta is commonly referred to as
Bolognese or has spoken incorrectly by
many Italian Americans and non-italians
bowling yes may I interrupt you for a
second yes you which is experience by
doing this together both for us as
friends and colleagues as a student do
you consider us friends I do I have some
pictures from my various trips to Italy
over the years I love that empty chair
perfect place for a beautiful woman nope
I'm good I'm all set
I love this shot Jordan in a chair alone
that seems to be a theme with you yeah I
see it sometimes I stand I walk I lay
I'm alone
yeah it's covered that yeah that's no
secrets at some autobiography you just
wrote and how was this basically this
was my routine I would wake up in the
morning exhilarated where's your chest
hair I removed the chest hair how did
you do that shaved it off what it feels
great to be in the sunshine without any
hair between your skin and the sunshine
anything south of the chest gets shaved
south of the chest well yeah that's a
private matter you're gonna be shaving
your genitals while we're in Italy I
need to know before I get on this plane
with you well you see I haven't asked
you about your bathroom habits and nor
do I intend to I Drive and I'll be
shaving
I'll be shaving my face and that's it
maybe you should try my way which is to
shave more than your face it's important
that I have a hairless body when I go
with you to Italy I'm asking you to try
something new and suddenly you say I
want you to try something new and it
involves me shaving my body that sounds
like you want something to happen
between us you know I hadn't thought of
it but it's a great idea let us together
our nude bodies entwine who said
anything about our nude bodies entwine
I'm telling you why don't you try
something new why don't you try
something arguably European and the
Shelf shed yourself of unnecessary hair
I think you mean a lot more than that
when you say try something new and try
something European I think you're
talking about something else not just
shaving my body and I think you know it
I think you're talking about and it's
not gonna happen despite your greatest
fantasies all of your dreams every
picture you take that has an empty chair
in it I know what you're imagining a
hairless naked coma
[Applause]
you